in a few moments we will raise the
Finnish flag at the NATO headquarters
for the first time
from today
31 Flags will fly together a symbol of
our unity and our solidarity
joining NATO is good for Finland it is
good for Nordic Security
and it's good for NATO as a whole
Finland brings substantial and highly
capable forces
expertise on National resilience and
years of experience working side by side
with NATO allies
I'm deeply proud to welcome Finland as a
full-fledged member of our alliance
and I look forward to also welcoming
Sweden as soon as possible
at times like this friends and allies
are more important than ever
and Finland now has the strongest
friends and allies in the world
President Putin
wanted to slam NATO's door shut
today we show the world that he failed
that aggression and intimidation do not
work
instead of less NATO he has achieved the
opposite more NATO
and our door remains firmly open
president
thank you for your outstanding
leadership and commitment and for
leading Finland into the most successful
Alliance in history so welcome it's
great to have you here welcome to the
Lions thank you it's great to be here Mr
Secretary General dear yes I want to
thank you you have been with us all the
way I remember we discussed quite deeply
about NATO and Finnish membership
already
2021 when you brought your Council to
Finland
uh I guess we have been talking after
that by phone or by meeting
almost tens of times
so it is a great day for Finland and I
want to
see that it is an important day for NATO
too
security and stability are those
Elements which we feel
very strongly and
well we can all think that if people can
live in secured
stable circumstances that's the basic
element of happy life and you I guess
know that things are very happy already
now
I would also
see that this is a process from 30 to 31
and like you said
very nearby future
to 32 that is that the workforce with
this membership very hard we are doing
that together with them together with
you and that will continue from Finish
point also Swedish membership is most
important but once again
stability and security
I wish that we can give our share of
increasing that in the
defense Alliance we have
we have time for a few questions
please
from Finland Mr President how historic
is this moment he was born 1948.
NATO was established 1949.
well
I will have my 75 years
birthday today and NATO comes next year
but surely we have seen many
you have described many moments being
historic in this process I guess this is
the day
most historic to us and to
to our partners too
okay we have Ule the lady just behind
with a microphone yeah
uh so uh historic day but without Sweden
how can Finland help Sweden to get into
NATO and how will NATO proceed with the
Swedish uh Sweden to be Allied and then
one more question to Mr ninister do you
feel released relieved
surely from the result but I want to
tell you that the whole process it
hasn't been that tough in a way we have
had so good cooperation all the time and
full trust at least we have in Finland
all the time it has been very clear that
in due time we will be members so
basically the process hasn't been that
actually demanding
but surely it's a relief when we can
repeat but security and
stability that is a relief for all of us
to Sweden we have all the way been
working together with Sweden we continue
helping them as much as possible I have
been discussing
with the president everyone you have
been discussing many times and I think
at least I am I have a very positive
outlook for that
just to to concur with the president
Nina Stone we are both in closer contact
with Ankara with uh with President
adugan I I went to Ankara a few weeks
ago and that was where we agreed on the
way forward both when it comes to this
fine ratification of uh of Finland but
also that we agreed to restart the
process in what we call the trilateral
permanent mechanism with Finland Sweden
and turkey to follow up on the
trilateral memorandum outstanding that
was assigned in Madrid president ninster
was there we were almost there and and
now it's important to follow up and to
ensure that one important element which
is actually to finalize the the
membership process not only for Finland
but also for Sweden is fully implemented
and my message is and has been also in
my meetings in that not only Finland but
also Sweden has delivered on the
commitments they have made under that
trilateral agreement so
nothing should hinder or be an obstacle
for also the final
ratification of of also Sweden to become
a member this is a top priority for the
alliance this is important for me
personally and all allies agree that we
should try to finalize the accession
also Sweden as soon as possible so we
will continue to work on this and
hopefully you can have Sweden soon let
me add one more thing and that is that
Finland and Sweden applied together
that it's on in May last year old in
June one month after all allies also
turkey
invited Finland and Sweden to become
members and uh and and so far this has
been the fastest succession process in
NATO's modern history
I also stated that of course the most
important thing is not that Finland and
Sweden joins exactly at the same time
the most important thing is that they
join as soon as possible today Finland
is joining and then we will ensure that
also Sweden can join as soon as possible
okay we'll go to Ard
Christian
Russia always says that the enlargement
of NATO towards the east or the North
threatens Russia and what do you or are
you afraid that the
Finnish accession is also a pretext for
Russia to yes to see Russia surrounded
to be threatened by the West
actually
like you said Russia has been repeating
that and president to put in two kids up
very clearly
in December 21 and that was one of the
reasons why the discussion in Finland
Rose
we don't want to be
or we do not want that others say what
we should do and what we can't do I had
full belief surely on NATO NATO won't
close its doors but nevertheless
that was
Russians in a way tried to create a
sphere around them
and well we are not a sphere
and
all these the result we see today
over there
thank you Ida halekane from ilta Sanam
this day means a big change for Finland
security uh how does how big this change
is and what does it mean for us and for
NATO
well like
Secretary General told we have been on
board quite a long time we are enhanced
partners with the Sweden now more than
10 years and during that time we have
all the time being developing our
capabilities of working together with
NATO so the change is not that radical
it has actually taken place year after
year
by us getting closer that the same fits
with Sweden too surely you know daily
life I do not believe that
people see very much changes but like I
started with is that
I'm sure that things feel themselves
more secured more feeling that we are
living in a stable no Europe a stable
world and that is most important for us
today Finland will become a full member
of the alliance and that means that from
today on finnan will participate in all
NATO
structures military civilian activities
and also be at the table in all NATO
meetings and also have a vote and be
part of decision making within the
alliance but of course most importantly
what happens from today on is that
Finland will be covered by NATO's
Ironclad security guarantees our article
five that says that an attack on one
Ally will be regardless and attack on
all one for all all for one then the
president is absolutely right when he
says that this has been a gradual
development of Finland and Sweden have
many years been very close partners then
after we invited Finland and Sweden in
June last year they gotten other status
invite T status which is a special
status that actually trigger the process
where we started to integrate Finland
Sweden into our military and civilian
structures but of course it is a
different thing to be close and an
invitee and to be a full member which is
the case for Finland from today on
thank you very much colleagues this
wraps up this press point but we'll see
you at the flag raising ceremony thank
you thank you